this session
is brought to you by design singapore
council national agency for design in
singapore
and is supported by trampoline limited
melbourne digital
and national design center this webinar
is part of a series of engagement and
sharing sessions
under the good design research
initiative which aims to help designers
and design enterprises in singapore find
a unique value proposition
in designing for impact through research
experimentation
and a network of knowledge partners this
event is also part of the national
design center's thematic lineup
on singapore our home information on the
good design research and other programs
in this month's lineup
will be shared with you during the
course of the session
now before we proceed i would like to
highlight a few housekeeping rules
should you encounter any technical
issues please reach out to us
to the zoom chat function we ask for
your patience and understanding should
the conditions be less than perfect
during this webinar your audio will be
on newt however we welcome your
questions throughout the sessions
at any point in time through the zoom q
and a function
when posting a question please state
your name and
if you have any specific panelists whom
you'd like to respond to your question
finally please be informed that this
session will be recorded
now allow me to introduce the speakers
and this afternoon's program
my colleague huemei from the design
singapore council
will be joining us shortly to share an
overview of the good design research
initiative
after which francis will be speaking
about inclusive design for education and
work readiness
with over 20 years of professional
experience francis had collaborated with
mncs on product innovation
mentored startups translated and
commercialized
various technologies over the past five
years he has been actively involved in a
social sector
and presently he is the ceo of
trampoline a non-profit that is spun out
of asta
trampoline aims to use technology to
develop sustainable social service
models
for the underprivileged disadvantage and
the vulnerable
last but not least we have ian ceo of
mormon digital who will be speaking on
inclusive design
using conversational ai ian turn is a
computer engineer by training by
adventure into marketing to bring brands
and organizations to global markets
previously based in china for eight
years he brings his wealth of experience
in international marketing
politics and economic know-how to
companies
or some of you here might wonder that
this isn't really like inclusive design
but fred not marwin actually has strong
plans for expanding their business into
inclusivity
and through this session you will hear
more about inclusive projects that they
have embarked on
without further ado i will now hand you
over to hueme who will be giving you a
quick introduction on the good design
research initiative
we may please thanks jericho for the
quick introduction
and thank you all for taking the time to
join us today
so i'm not sure how many of you out
there would have heard about the good
design research initiative
and therefore i would like to take some
time to share more on the background
so firstly i'll be sharing on why good
design research is important
and then secondly on the key elements of
the initiative
its importance in today's context was
very apparent when we conducted our
research
in close consultation with designers and
design enterprises
we interviewed over 40 of them with most
of them recognizing
that design for impact which is also
what most will recognize
as good design will help them shape
their value proposition
and stand out in the global marketplace
and on the demand side there has always
been a recognition of the role that
design can play
in mitigating the world's complex issues
this is especially apparent
in the covet pandemic that we are
experiencing right now
and the design innovation that we need
goes beyond simply improving user
experiences for the retail and fmb
but that it requires deep research
and there is a clear need for this deep
research that is fundamental
to good design
however good design research requires
two key elements
that are not always possible with
smaller design firms
first it requires a significant
investment of resources
and second an ecosystem of strong
network of partners
therefore the good design research
therefore with the good
with the good design research the
council plans to bridge
these two resource gaps the first part
of the good design research initiative
aims to build a strong network and
ecosystem
to foster multidisciplinary
collaborations that are necessary
for design impact projects we are hoping
to achieve these
through this webinar as well as the
subsequent sharing and engagement
sessions
the second part of the good design
research initiative
aims to support exploratory projects
through open calls
this support includes sponsorship
publicity support as well as mentorship
and with these two key phases the good
design research
encourages designers to develop unique
value propositions
in particular it seeks to support
designers embarking on projects with
deep explorations into these three key
tracks
identity and culture systems and
processes
as well as new technologies it also
seeks to support projects
with a focus on design impact so i hope
this brief overview gives you a rough
idea of what the good design research
initiative is all about
and if you would like to find out more
information about this initiative you
may scan the qr code
on the bottom right and with this i'll
pass the time back to jerica
thank you huemi now before i move into
presentation by francis who i'd like to
understand from our attendees on your
understanding
and impression of inclusive design a
poll question should be appearing on
your screens now
with three options on how we can engage
youth with special needs
choose the option that you feel be most
effective
first a drag and drop game that teaches
basic life skills
second a visual timer represented by a
fish tank filling up with water
and third both items okay i guess most
of you have given your
answers we will now close the poll
okay so most of you 62 percent of you
she thinks it's both items and followed
by
a a dragon drug unit teaches us basic
life skills
we will now invite francis to actually
take the stage and share with you more
about the design
considerations behind this poll as well
of his presentation on inclusive design
for education
and work readiness francis please
hi everyone good afternoon
okay today i will share about a few
things i will
start with talking about sharing about
trampolines
who we are how do we came about i also
talked about
some inclusive design with some
demonstration in real life that you can
help you have a more concrete
understanding with that i will actually
go into a specific case study
uh focusing on the digital product to
help you get a better understanding how
include design come about and who can be
involved in those design
lastly i would like to extend an
invitation for all of you join us in
this journey
okay a little story about trembling and
how the name comes about
we actually take inspiration from our
senior minister taman
in the speech given at san holland he
actually mentioned that
our singapore model is not uh stop
promoting social welfare
rather we believe in the philosophy of
social trembling
we've helped those who fall to the gaps
to get back up
and uh what about trampoline how does
how did we come about
we are actually a non-profit uh it's a
spinner from a star
trampoline is actually founded by a
group of enthusiastic volunteers
they are usually there most of them are
engineers and scientists by training
they aspire to give back to the society
using their experience and expertise
through today's presentation i hope you
get a sense of
how different party can come together to
make this society more inclusive through
inclusive design lastly also touch about
other than our volunteers we also have
other stakeholders
that are on this platform like
caregivers themselves
we also have pwds people with
disabilities who are with us
in our journey in developing our product
in short
trampoline is like a platform where
everyone come together
contribute idea share their experience
to make products and services
for those who are underserved in our
society
now if you look at our world uh whether
is it the desktop or the web banner you
are
assessing it's usually built for the
majority for about body
while neurotypical so what about for
those who are
the minority population such as
the senior even though they are we are
aging population we are more and more
senior
in our society you with special needs
and people who are physically disabled
are the products our environment our
infrastructure
easily accessible or similarly
accessible to them
for example if i visually impair can i
look at the screen like what most of you
are assessing to this webinar and set it
answer is obviously
no can we make live and reflect easier
and better for those who are underserved
through inclusive design so we need to
look at the client profile that who are
we servicing
when we design products and services in
mind
so i will share some of the product and
services that has been designed by
trampoline
and i will i'll share you to answer a
few questions
who can be involved what does trembling
do what is the inclusive design all
right
so take for example the icon or left
corner called book
group is also known as volunteer
optimizer
and interestingly vote was actually
developed by a group of volunteers
how did it come about through their own
volunteering experience
the group volunteers find that they can
make things easier
better more productive how so
right registration can be made easier to
for example barcode scanner
right attendance can make
activity can be made easier through
matching if i have volunteering for one
organization
i can find and my interest for example
is this
is a skill i want here as an iq person
through a system it can easily match me
to organization where those volunteering
activities available
and hence you can see that as a
volunteer you can also participate
in in in design that's like for a
targeted group right
right and what about the next one i look
at the second line cons
smart bfa bfa stands for barrier free
assets why is it smart well the team
that developed this solution
they are actually use youtube user
themselves and if you put your song
in the front of someone who is a
wheelchair user people think they will
amenities services like any one of us do
for example
if you're on a wheelchair it can be a
manual wheelchair
it can be a electric electrical chair
now
the slide and the slope on the pavement
make a difference to whether you can get
from point a
to point b similarly if there is wrong
word ahead
and if you are working on paper that's
very narrow you could get stuck
and based on the bitcoin itself it's
probably very difficult for you to make
a new turn
and get yourself out there so you could
actually be stuck in a place for very
long
the third one is that for accessing to
amenities such as our train station
usually there's only one way to access
your train station
and to access the lift to lead to the
platform if you do not know the way
you have a hard time navigating around
the next thing they are always looking
for is
toilets a wheelchair accessible toilet
so these are things that we took for
granted but to them it's important to
have this information
before they even begin their journey and
this is the reason why
that day themselves user they work with
other designers
uh system engineers to come up together
to apps to help them navigate
from point to point the other one i will
touch one is i
gain bottom meter corner this is
actually a
gamification software to help um
children and young adult with learning
difficulties or with special needs to
learn numeracy
life skills as a basic language skill
it's actually developed by
parents themselves educators designers
engineers come together they put their
head together
and develop this eye gain because if you
are familiar with special education
school
they are usually half day so what do the
children do for the rest of the half day
one way to engage them is through game
which
make them learn at the same time and
that's how i gain was conceived
and developed and currently is being
applied
in schools so
then the question will you have is okay
yeah i hear you about inclusive design
how does it look like how do you create
a product
well look these are all good questions
so before i go there i
we touch on uh something closer to our
heart closer to our daily life
for example how many wheelchair
accessible swimming food
are you aware they are in singapore now
how does a child with muscular dye
trophy
for example brush his teeth how does a
student with
hearing impairment learn in class or in
lecture hall
or how does some hearing impairment
carry out a conversation
how does people visual impairment travel
from place away including travel to a
baby
and what kind of job can person autism
fine
now look at the picture on the left have
you seen this type of two brush before
or have you tried using such two brush
before you can see that it's actually
designed in certain way
and if you look at the handle what does
it tell you
it's designed for someone who need to
grip it with
different grip so it could be this
person uh
either have um fine motor skill issue
or they have strength issue and that's
why the design is done in this way
so a simple thing like toothbrush can be
designed to allow someone
have an easier life daily life living
rush achieve
very very simple thing that we need to
do daily but we took for granted because
we are not affected right
so this design is not very difficult but
uh it's just need a little bit of
consideration and you can see that
it's so creative they are on this
picture you sell their research design
so i'm quite sure your image if you
stretch your imagination
you would have seen more what about the
picture on the right what are they
are they pictures for kid to learn uh
if you have if you have kids with
learning difficulty especially autism
you know that victoria style picture
help them to communicate when they're
young
because most most of the young children
with autism get a social communication
deficit meaning that
they may have problems speaking
communicating what they want
a picture helps them for example it
could be a yes
it could be a no it could be unhappy
this will help you to understand them
and communicate with them these are
tools these two on the right is also
called
augmentative and alternative
communication tools
now um
let's come to daily life you can see in
this picture on the left that's graceful
that she she's working with a senior you
can see that similar actually have a hit
he's hurt his hand and leg amputated
and he can access the swimming pools
because
they actually have a they actually have
a slope slide that allows someone
who is physically a disabled sit on the
platform and actually move them down to
the
it's not possible for them to just jump
into any pool
this pool are specially designed so
including our public amenities like
swimming pool
has to be designed to be more inclusive
so that people who are disabled can
actually participate in leisure sports
on the right hand side you can see that
that's an athlete plays a certain games
and is designed for for certain purposes
now you look at that picture
this game probably is testing what does
it has it has their fine motor skill
dexterity and probably the ability to
control their movement right
most of us are probably familiar with
eating the um
one the gold medal in environment
but there are actually many many games
like that paragraph design
for people with different abilities or
disabilities
and get them involved in our life and to
be more integrated in our society
so you can see the two design and just
sound design for daily life for sports
and next
i come to learning remember i mentioned
what if you have a hearing impairment
how do you communicate communicate on a
daily basis
do you use sign languages and even for
sign languages
i'm not too sure you're aware there's a
singapore sign language there's an
english sign language that's
american standard for english language
alone
right so you have many language you
learn so can we use two
to overcome because one of the question
is that how many of us are prepared to
learn sign languages
in order to communicate someone who is
hearing
uh chances are uh not many of one not
many of us
right so you look at that now you look
at the picture on the left top left
corner
it's actually a speech to text software
and you can download all the software
to your ios or google play so as you
speak
you actually translate your speak into
language and two words
so that someone can follow the
conversation so this is very
particularly useful
in a classroom setting where people can
learn uh
as the teachers speak and they actually
can learn and we follow the classes
the other picture you can see like where
is the adaptive keyboard
mouse or pointers it helps
it helps for them to access digital
products some people need a bigger
keyboard so that they can see and type
some people even specially design mouse
so that they can play around it could be
that they don't have five motor skills
right or if you if you are you will see
someone who has stroke position
their problem with modeling their
fingers so all these design
as you see on this one help them to
learn to communicate
us to overcome the barrier and most of
the products
are designed for level matching for
majority with slight consideration
you actually uh for example for text
speech exactly can actually
attend classes they can use computer to
learn they can submit assignments
so with the same thought process we
actually applied those
into our own products it's smart dfa
that i touched about
about just now i gained or um
earlier so let me touch on smart bfa
i mentioned about some of the challenges
that face so if you're a user that face
the challenges you need to know where is
the washroom
or wheelchair you need to plan your
route ahead from point a to b
you need to know exactly where to move
to get to the train station
and then to the live in the train
station to get the platform to take the
train
you also need to not actually exit from
the train station
where is the path to go in order for you
to get out of the train station
and to me with your destiny all this
information need to be
known before that's what view i'm not
too sure are you aware that most of the
time for wheelchair relations
they don't they don't they usually
trying to minimize
drinking before they go out because
looking for
wheelchair accessible pilot is always an
issue
all right and they also need to make
sure that the battery are fully charged
just in case there's a road work and
they need to make a big detour to get to
their destination
these are things that we took for
granted right but that's not true for a
wheelchair user
this is a reason why they need real-time
navigation information
they also need up-to-date point-to-point
accessible route
what do you make access around remember
i mentioned about
work if there's a roadwork the route
that was accessible
would not be accessible for the next
couple months
and this is free why they need this
information and how can this information
be communicated
by the community of users they can
update each other i'm at a
point i'm for example location x there's
a
robot going on try to avoid using this
round so
simple idea to uh apps it can be used
and allow users to navigate
and allow them get out of the house do
what they're supposed to do whether you
work or be
grocery shopping
now look at these pictures itself uh if
you
let me talk a bit about dementia in
order to help you understand
a senior with dementia usually their
short-term memory are
impacted but their long-term memory is
usually intact
so it takes a while for for for the
disease to
slowly chip with a long-term memory now
what can
help to make the long-term memory in
that we
copy the new neuron pathway meaning that
keep
exposing them to the same content same
information
how so there's something called
reminiscent therapy
so you can look at pleasant memories
example
their visit to chinatown right it also
can be something
something quite common in their time for
example
um records a record players
or food or food there's a regulation
that they can associate with that time
so for example one day uh uh
mid-afternoon is coming
it could be the moon particular
so by capturing this content we actually
put it inside inside these apps
and what we observe is that in actual
practice the rare medicine
the therapies expose the content to the
senior
and engage them in this game so we
actually
what we does is that we work with the
therapies and the caregiver we digitize
the game
so that the caregiver can actually play
with the uh cme at home
and the senior can play among themselves
so what does this do
it slows down uh the reaction due to
dementia it also promotes social
interaction among the smear
we actually can see that seniors are
happier when they can
connect with each other and connect
people around them
and there's also an element of fun all
game should have an element
next we will ask the question why do we
need to have eye gain
you have to we if you see from the lens
of someone with
learning challenges yeah their brain are
wired differently they face many
barriers to
learning because like i mentioned before
our education content are usually built
for the majority
so i take a very simple example if i
look
at a straight line you may not appear
straight to me it may appear
curve so if you ask me to cut a cape i
could
keep cutting this way if you can see my
hand now the reason is because
a straight line appears curved too
so my so what happened is that i will
keep doing this movement
how do i train this actually i can one
way is that i
i i have your hand and through this
movement i keep asking to this
recruitment
so after a while your brain will train
to see kevlar as straight right
so there are different ways to train so
is it the person cannot see
or they can see but their brain process
the information differently
or they have weak estimation they cannot
know how hard to time
for example and if you cut a kick too
hard you will break the part right
so by understanding what is causing the
challenges
we actually can design possible
intervention
and we actually incorporate some of this
into a video game
to help them learn
then i'll come to such on another
increasingly
increasing amount of population there
are more and more people diagnosed with
autism spectrum disorder or commonly
known ast
they it could be due to better diagnosis
or early diagnosis but in short
why is it that most of them have
challenges in debating to our society
it's simple we are like offline and they
come from different planets
they don't understand the way we think
they don't understand
the way we interact uh why do we behave
in the way we do
okay this is one of the reason why most
of them
can they have fake challenges learning
in the mainstream school
or getting into employment so i'll give
you an example
if you tell someone to finish the work
asap so asap is it one minute
one day one hour so it's not very
concrete but most of us can somehow
through working with other people we get
the same asap could mean by the end of
the day
but that's not so for someone who is on
autism they prefer very concrete
information
so one way to communicate with them is
can you finish this piece of work
by the end of today but process end of
the end of day can mean 12 am
by 5 pm and on day if you have any
questions regarding your work
please please look for mrs nyer who is
your english teacher
these are very very specific
instructions that they can understand
so allow me to jump into a certain case
study to give you a better appreciation
of
how improved design is picking practice
from gathering the problem statement the
pinpoint
to the design process and the validation
validation process
as i mentioned earlier uh you need to
understand the target audience who are
you trying to serve
what is their challenges what are you
trying to overcome
so for i gained the first pilot project
that we did
with the school was for young children
children and youth between seven to
eighteen years old
they have modeled to severe multiple
discipline
in schooling uh usually most of the iq
are below 50.
so what we want to achieve is that can
we help them learn live skills
learn basic numeracy skills as well as
basic
language view and the content
has to be localized to help them learn
better and we hope to have very
interactive adaptive game features so
that
it keep their interest and you keep
their learning motivation
so what we have does is that we we
actually go into classroom
observe how teacher actually conduct
lessons in the extra classroom to this
group of users
and what are the challenges to face
what's the teacher to student ratio
when the teacher is engaging one student
what happened to the right side student
are they paying attention or are they
disengaged so from this
style we find that uh digital gaming can
augment
uh classroom one of the reason i
mentioned was because
after school they they tend to be quite
free right
so uh through this journey itself we
actually invite the caregivers
to give feedback we work with the
teachers we always
like professional to design the game to
digitize the content
we design the user interface with our
designers itself
you can see it's very clean one color
and that's intense and that is too many
iterations to know that
why is cleaner one color because it
minimizes distraction
to the user they know exactly where to
touch
so what are the key features and
learning points we have
gamification help to motivate kids all
of us love game
we love to be a gay wheeler to be angry
so gamification definitely help
but that's not the only factors what
about modules
you need to design models with different
levels so that kids can progress
and also they can set themselves as
challenges know that when level one i
want to go to level two
so game level uh gives very concrete
path
for someone to learn and pace themselves
and third is it has to be related to
that daily living
remember our target profiles of young
children
and daily living that apply to singapore
content for example
you want to teach them food you have to
be chicken rice or chocolate
or masala if you talk about pasta and
something it may not resonate with them
and the last one would be you have to be
intuitive they look at the screen they
know that i'm supposed to touch this
part
and will not be confused by a lot of
color or a lot of sound
because remember we need to be mindful
of their cognitive capacity as well
okay so you look at the left and the
right the content is something that
as you walk work with the teacher work
with the caregiver we find that these
are
the knowledge that will help them not
only
in learning but in uh and towards that
journey their journey towards
independent living
the right side is something that we need
to design how do we
impart this knowledge to them so you can
see that you
not in so you can see that in terms of
inclusive design
sometimes you need more than one type of
skill set you need a content developer
in this case the educator themselves
on the right hand side you need
engineers they are game designers that
interfere with designers
right and you also need caregiver to
provide him
how does that child actually use what
are the challenge they face
what are the do you remember i show you
the the
mouse the keyboard yeah so those are the
one that you need to take note
as well so like i mentioned
just now the key considerations are
physical limitation
cognitive limitation or the behavioral
challenges
eventual attention span having a lot of
colors
in the screen may distract you or having
a lot of sound
you may be more motivated by triggering
a sound of music than
in actually learning social so all these
considerations have to be taken inside
understand how it affects learning from
the user interface
with a content presentation for example
you need to have more words
or less words should there would be a
certain font size
those are the design considerations
so you look at physical concept
consideration now if you
remember you see a picture of someone
who has
five multiple skill challenges you need
a wider area to touch
and hence you need larger space between
objects so remember
our target audience was children with
multiple disabilities
let's object on the screen right wider
space so that they can navigate
and they can touch and click interact
with surfaces
yellow yeah one is also um
do they understand why it's drag and
drop drag drop to you or to most of us
may be
very intuitive but for some other kids
one is they cannot do drag and drop
partly because of physical uh disability
they may not have the strength to prove
from one place
to another the other thing is that if
their attention levels
it can become very confusing if they
need to point
clear at one point move together but
they may lose they may lose focus along
the way
the cognitive consideration that even
among
our profile or learner with disabilities
they have different levels
right they start from different place so
we need to have level of difficulty
language them
so you need to design a game where it
can target this population
yet within this population it has level
of difficulty
so that certain tasks are made simpler
for entry level
certain time a more difficult or
advanced level
for example if i say forward tower into
half
that will be simple what if i say four
tower into third
now that is more difficult right
similarly uh you need to give feedback
whether they are right or wrong so that
it help them to know that
they got the right answer and they can
move on to the next stage or they know
that i make a mistake here i should come
back and read them
i touched on attention span which is why
you can see the design was very clean
same color same color scheme throughout
the entire interface
this is meant more to capture their
attention and prevent them from getting
distracted
and then and the instruction you can see
that is very easy to follow
you encourage them play and also allow
them time to process the information
now some of our future plans is that we
want to have more content
so with more teachers coming onboard
they can give us more or caregiver
coming onboard
we can have more content targeting wider
audience right
because we also have more robust
infrastructure so that
when you develop a content we can click
quickly deploy
and scale data we also can have better
user interface design or gamification
for example just now you saw the rabbit
can arabic be more interactive have a
personality of themselves
so that it's more engaging for the for
for the students
and the users now after talking to
you we hope that you can get more and
more people to participate
uh in this journey so so whether you are
caregivers you are designers
furniture designers or engineers uh we
hope to hear from you
so far for some of the problem statement
will be like accessibility
we want to develop human capacity can we
change the environment
it can be applied to game design
activity
design or even environmental design okay
i'll show you this picture right so for
example
if you are talking about broom what
happened if i have
if i have a problem holding on remember
the tool brush
can you design the handle such that i
can learn
how to sleep okay you do you realize
that this
room doesn't have a very very very uh
inclusive design in terms of handler
that's one the two uh second one robot
for someone a social communication
deficit we
notice a communication pattern can this
this context
content be digitized for example to a
robot
or through an interesting game encourage
them to talk
so that they can help to form in their
mind how to go about
initial conversation sustaining a
conversation
closing a conversation appropriately and
this will help them make friends
and we have friendship conversation if
you connected and you feel integrated
right
the third is office design okay for
example for office itself
can we have adjustable light filters
some people are very sensitive to lights
or bright lights
if you have adjustable light filters
itself it allow
it allow the environment to be uh to be
adjusted very
uh attack without without massive
renovation
similarly for chess if you will if you
are aware someone with a
attention deficit when they sit on a
chair sometimes they tend to rock
right so can the chair be in such a way
that it can absorb certain movements so
that
the person will rocking it help them to
regulate cell record
and then you bring them attention back
to what the task
okay i have more let's come to the end
of the
my presentations and uh
uh okay and if you have some question i
could take it now or i could do it take
it at the end of the
presentation itself thank you francis
your presentation illustrated the
in-depth research and understanding
that's required to design products
and services for people with
disabilities now attendees if
any questions or thoughts about
princesses sharing
feel free to drop them into the q and a
module so that we can bring them up for
discussion
during the q a segment later on
now let's take half a minute here to
actually understand from our audience
your opinions on hashtagging and how
accessible language is
a post should appear on your screens
right now with three options
on the ways which the term digital
accessibility can be formatted
which one would you think is the easiest
to read and understand
so first impressions count so don't take
too much time to answer this question
and close the poll now okay so the
majority
of you feel that option a is actually i
guess the most accessible and i guess
that's the right answer
we will now actually invite ian turn who
will be elaborating on the answer as
well as
sharing about his presentation on
designing using conversational ai
ian turn please hi everyone
thank you very much thanks jerica uh
yeah before i start i think most of you
are quite good in terms of
using the hashtag but to be honest when
i actually first started
i didn't actually realize the key
differences i've been using my hashtags
in smaller caps so this is one of the
important thing that why we need more
people
to be in this ecosystem to understand
more and come up with even better
inclusive design
so our journey started during this year
where we
are actually a marketing and advertising
agency
which specializes in marketing
technology and
as what uh jericho has mentioned earlier
on what made us actually
go into this journey of doing uh
inclusive design throughout technology
so it was quite an interesting journey
and i hope to share this journey with
everyone
on this call and hopefully we can
actually work towards helping more
people in the inclusive community to
come to to learn better
to train better actually enrich
themselves on the same landscape
this is just a little bit of the brands
that we work with globally
from our end and some of our key
strategic technology partners that we
work with
closely to develop our ai
and marketing technology okay
these are some of the key three martech
products that we have in this space but
today i'm just going to focus on
a lav which is the conversational ai
technology that we have and would like
to share a little bit more of what we
have been doing it with it so far
and looking forward to actually hear
more opinions and have an open
discussion later on to see how we can
actually bring this technology into more
people's life
so many people will ask me what is
uh conversational ai i just want to
illustrate this fact with this video
malaria isn't just any disease it's the
deadliest disease there's ever been
existed
mr
speak up and say malaria must die
one voice can be powerful but all of our
voices together
then okay so interestingly this is
actually what we actually been doing so
as you can see david beckham actually
has spoke
in nine different languages and actually
is still using the same video
so these are one of the key technology
that we're actually working on and
working towards
and working with different partners that
does emotion ai
as you can see uh they are actually
using uh emotion ai to actually
uh alter the the signs of his leaves so
that they can actually move and
talk as if they are speaking in
different languages
so these are interesting things so over
here at left
we propose to actually do conversations
plus ai but with a vernacular element to
it what is vernacular
we actually focus on language and
dialects speaking by the ordinary people
in a specific country or region
and especially in asean this is actually
a very important thing where
we do have a lot of vernacular languages
places like in philippines where
telecolon is used
thailand vietnam etc so in the asean
region
language is a very big barrier in terms
of learning so how do we actually use ai
to improve conversations
eliminate the language barrier
in a lot of different aspects our own
technology right now will be able to
support
over 30 languages and dialects worldwide
we just started our initiative in
singapore to learn the singlish language
as well
and that's the reason why we're actively
doing much more in the singapore market
and hopefully with this collaboration
talking to
people folks like you guys as well as we
design
simple console we can come up with more
products that can actually be able to
tap on this
conversational ai technology
as explained earlier on this is one of
our earliest projects that we actually
started off with
and uh i just wanted to give a stretch
this
this is how we made our first foray we
actually developed this technology
uh thinking that we want to actually use
it for ohm where you know going into an
elevator people pushing the wheelchair
they would actually have a lot of issues
in terms of communicating with the leaf
holding the leaf putting it
people that are you doing these
caregivers you you guys know what i'm
talking about this is actually an
important pain point and when actually
we took that pinpoint
and thinking of how we can actually use
our technology in terms of
compositional ai to communicate with the
leaf that's
what we actually came up with elevator
[Music]
lobby so as you can see this is not
rocket science it's just the ability to
understand different languages and
different dialects
to actually make contact with the leaf
and with this particular product we
actually
became more more supported in today's
how i put it in today's kobe situation
where there's a lot of
contactless technology needed and that's
why we are very fortunate to work with
uh the singapore government agencies as
well as partners as well as
uh we are going on trials with hitachi
elevator to actually test our particular
technology on their list
to make it uh truly accessible to not
only
uh folks that has uh uh trying to clear
themselves of this covet
but also looking at helping more people
with accessibility issues
how do we actually use this to actually
bring this technology
closer people could be able to do their
daily lives with all these kind of tools
a little bit on the technology side
which i think it would be interesting to
share
with folks over here every one of you
over here is that what is the key
technology behind conversational ai
in a simple way we just focus on three
main points over here
which is the nls or nlp which is widely
known as we call it natural language
simulation automatic speech recognition
asr
as well as text to speech which is the
conversational part of it where we are
able to
convert all the data or all information
from either speech to text
or text to speech so that we have a
common denominator to understand
the language b the language or the
context of the
instruction or the information that is
given
and through that we are able to reduce
everything to a common denominator
we apply this technology into different
solutions like from b2b solutions
where we work with industry focused
products to actually
develop some products over here as well
as b2c solutions where it's out in the
market for example
the contactless contactlessly that you
saw where we actually building up from
scratch
uh with this kind of solution to
integrate it into applications that can
be helped to the market and go to market
quite easily
behind all this i think we are also
working on the entire big data platform
which i will elaborate a little bit more
on
where how do we make use of all this
information especially in the
accessibility point of view
to learn more about behaviors about
users
and then we can actually develop better
even better products later on for all
these
users
next this is just an example of the text
to speech that we spoke of earlier on
as you can see our text to speech model
will be able to actually speak in a
natural form language if you notice over
here
uh the way they are speaking is not a
very pure robotic sense it's quite
natural
so we actually have that model that will
be able to cover anything from british
english
this the cantonese demo is just to let
you know that it understands different
dialects i'm not able to use the exact
same chinese words actually
because in the way where people are
pronouncing or talking in cantonese
it's more of a localized manner so
that's why i actually use this sentence
instead of the
original sentences that was duplicated
in different languages as well
okay so as you were talking
uh earlier on how does this
accessibility technology will be able to
help more as
as per what they have mentioned early on
we do notice that it's not only
able to help people in the inclusive
community it's actually able
accessibility also means that it allows
us to develop products that provides a
better user experience for all of us
even people like you and me everyone is
fair and square everyone out there
will be able to enjoy it so these are
some statistics that we actually know
especially for travel where a lot of
people from different countries still
find that language is a barrier
how can they have better products how
can they enjoy the experience much
better
and through this accessibility design i
just wanted to reiterate the fact that
we are designing it for everybody
and when through this design the more
people that will be able to contribute
today will be able to come up with
better customer experiences
a bit a bit of a fun fact about this
technology i just wanted to
share with all of you here how are we
able why is our technology good or how
is it accurate or why we are different
in the market
uh the way we are using a learning model
it was quite interesting where
all this natural language processing is
actually named after sesame street
so we have ernie we have bread so our
particular this model that we actually
use
the ernie model actually was the first
model that scored more than 90 on this
glue platform
glue matrix which is a machine
translation
natural language understanding kind of
score and they became the first one to
score more than 90
and how it does that was through using
chinese language
to learn chinese language they realized
that it can be also applied in learning
english
or other languages and make it even much
better in learning
so this is our one of our earliest
product that we came up with
it's actually a conference solution
where you can see over here
where we are able to translate and uh
interpret
simultaneously for solutions in english
and chinese in this case
uh it was one of the earliest products
we produced back in
late 2016 and 17. so this is uh one of
our key technology
and then we slowly reach the latest
language translation technology
we are very impressed
so from a market perspective i mean i
come from a marketing background right
as well malaysian this is actually a
very important market
static a gartner report has shown that
more than 50 percent of consumer facing
companies
will be using conversational ai as part
of their user experience or customer
experience
journey and this largely says that this
is a very big market and how we can
actually apply this conversational ai to
an
even wider larger space is true
accessibility which we
firmly believe in as well so i just
wanted
to highlight the fact that if we
actually go into this market the market
is really huge
and we'll be able to able to do
something and make it
sustainable some of our applied ai
solutions that we actually have did
uh here over here you can see that we
actually develop
unmanned customer service chaos for
hotels we also have
a information smart information chaos
that's running in
the hong kong airport which is on trial
right now where it's also
unmanned it provides information through
speech and recognizes speech
just now the contactless leaf we are
quite happy to be supported by the
ipi singapore to actually promote this
and work on growth global collaboration
with partners around the world
as you can see i've been i'm someone
that kind of believed a lot into
uh uh videos so i would just want to
show what we actually use our technology
in in this particular case
as you can see over here the captions
and you can see the background noises
what we are using in automotive right
now where uh there are
applications into uh self-driving uh
where we will be able to use uh
uh our voice controls in self-driving
cars
over here is an effect that we actually
using our technology to understand
or to hear even though with ambient
noises the accuracy of this
transcription
so what you see over here right now
below is real-time transcriptions
and this is just to prove that the
accuracy and transcription of our
technology is very accurate even though
there are a lot of ambient noises where
we actually use ai
to eliminate those noises in the
background
okay there are some in the application
of the technology besides
accessibility we're actually focusing
our technology our
our use of use of our technology in
vertical industry
reason being that we actually very focus
and make it more even more accurate
compared to our global competitors the
reason why we are able to
perform better on the blue score and
another metric for evaluating machine
translation over here you can see our
technology are left over here we
outperform platforms like google ifly
tech microsoft fight to all the
big global players in the fmb in the
hotel industry which is one our
hospitality is one of our focus
we also working on it in education in
fintech and the automotive industry as
you have seen earlier on
accessibility for us is a horizontal
where you try to apply
the technology and make it even more
accessible across all the different
industries that i spoke of earlier on as
well
our technology is uh felt in the us
is we have patents found in the us and
china as well the basis of this
technology in terms of natural language
understanding
due to many years of accumulation
coming to the end of my presentation one
of the
tests that we're actually doing is
actually in the line of application of
education and i think earlier on francis
has shared very well with uh the stuff
that he's doing and i mean
for example francis will be a terrific
partner for us to actually work with
together
in terms of how do we help the inclusive
community to learn better through better
design
of the learning tools that it would have
one of key things why we are focusing on
education is that we are
we firmly believe that with the use of
ai or technology we will be able
to level the playing field between the
inclusive community and the globe
and every talent will have a chance to
outshine itself by learning better
through ai as well as using ai as a tool
to equip them with better skills and
enhance their abilities to
outperform in the same roles that they
are doing compared to
say a normal person as well so over here
we are
we we do have a platform education
portal where
we are helping the uh inclusive
community to actually learn much better
through videos online and through
watching the videos transcribing the
videos
understanding your videos through audio
learning the blank they will be able to
understand language in a better way and
through the design
of the game gamification as well to make
sure that there will be a
gamified way they will be able to learn
much effective and much better
uh compared to stuff one of the key
features here of the use of technology
is through the multilingual
transcription
keyword identification we are able to
understand the keywords within
the whole of the video identify what are
the important things to learn
take them away and use them as a form of
a fill in a blank for
kids or for the people to actually for
the inclusive community to learn
by failing in the blanks and learning it
properly through enjoying watching a
video
is what we call immersive learning
anyway we are also able to use our
technology in voice recognition grading
where they can actually speak back and
we'll be able to recognize a voice
similar like
what you see in tarot okay where they
grade you on how you sing we will be
able to grade in terms of the intonation
the pronunciation
the tone of the speech to see whether
the particular person is speaking
properly
and how we can help the the the learner
to actually learn much better
okay to close this
uh session uh of course i would like to
first thank uh
uh design singapore council for inviting
me to work on this particular chat
session together with francis and
i've really learned a lot myself as well
and i'm coming here to also learn from
all of us all of you here
and see how we can actually work
together in accessibility innovations if
you have any
innovations out there we are happy to
see how we can actually provide even
more help with our ai technology
in terms of product design how we can
actually help in terms of your product
uh
design process and the final product as
well as people that are doing this
uh user experience using user interface
design how we can actually better
enhance the whole experience through
conversational ai true multilingual
emulating
language barrier all right with this i
just want to end with a quote from bill
gates that ai can be our friend do not
be afraid of it
thank you very much and i would like to
hand it back over to
jerica thank you very much thank you ian
turn thank you for the sharing is
really interesting to learn more about
the various applications of
conversational ai
we're now moving into the q and a
segment and i would like to invite both
francis and ian turn back to join us
as panelists and actually i see quite a
few questions that have been posted on
the q and a module
i will try our best definitely to see
what we can answer today but if we don't
we'll follow up with you right after
today's webinar so please feel free to
keep them coming
our first question comes from don and
his director
at francis actually two questions
actually don's question is about
inclusive design
and if trampoline has consulted with
persons with disability during the
development stages of your
projects her next part of the question
covers the type of users
which trampoline works with is it
limited to just caregivers teachers and
parents
francis would like to take this question
sure right
so in our in our productive development
itself we will involve people with
disability and non-disabled person
so for example for smart bfa which i
share
is actually developed by users who are
uh by user of youtube themselves they
are disabled
so i have engineers and scientists on
the team
so they are both developers and users
and they have outreached the same
community
and so the answer is yes but we also we
also involve non-disabled for example
designers some of the engineers you know
so we have a team
inclusive right
the other questions he asked is about um
uh i know tom personally i met her
before by the way
i don't if you remember recall so we are
here with engineers uh we are quite
happy to reach out and one of the
um we're trying to form different
communities for example research
community
it can give a better idea
to come up with evidence-based practices
and evidence-based partners and services
this is a very good idea and we are
definitely open to have
further discussion right okay
okay thanks francis now next question is
from
khan and director at both panelists
actually
so the question is about does research
does the research on children cover
across various cultures
and do you think culture plays a role in
the different learning processes that
the children might have
okay again maybe i'll go ahead first all
right go ahead don't worry
yes i think culture play a part so i
give you a very specific example
for like someone with artistic we know
for different cultures some culture tend
to be more expressive
and they tend to value um in individual
where some culture tend to be more team
more group based so you can see the
difference so for example if you
would like to see some of the series
itself you can see
those who are from let's say western
country
they tend to be more vocal more
expensive as compared to those in asian
society
so culture that's great
would you like to add anything on to
that yeah i'm sure i think khan i
actually know khan as well so
khan is a very good designer as well
he's a part of our business of purpose
community
so uh thanks khan hi how are you so i
think uh i think this particular
question is very important and that's
the reason why we're actually coming in
a lot of cultures they have a inbuilt or
in-depth um
and dated kind of thoughts towards
learning especially in asian countries
like us i think
francis has highlighted and through
design how do we take this approach
totally different and how do we
share with uh facilitators to parents to
uh caregivers there's a different way to
learn i think this is a
actually a very interesting thing and
it's also a huge challenge in
change management we usually call it in
technology terms
how do we actually enable people to take
their mind off a different tool
to learn a different way to learn i
think this is always a very important
part we are still learning
we are learning especially in this asean
region where it's quite diverse
in india it's also very diverse uh where
how do we learn it more effectively and
how do we change the way
uh the the for inclusivity
how do these kids will be able to learn
better compared to their
their their other peers and if they are
slightly
uh disadvantaged in this particular
sense how do we bring them back again
to the same level playing field that i
have everything i think that's something
that's really interesting
and i think it's very important to
educate both the facilitator the parents
the teachers
as well as the uh then the kid only yeah
hope that helps yeah that's just indeed
very insightful
um the next question actually is
targeted at friends
francis so this is one of the challenge
statements we should cover in our
presentation said earlier
and this is from denise so denise is
asking why is there little social
interaction
between asd individuals since preschool
francis would you be able to help to
elaborate on that okay ken
uh just like any one of us even people
who are on
asd yeah they are different every
individual is different
some are probably some are probably more
vocal others are less
but in general why we associate social
communication deficit with asd is
because
they can they tend to they tend to speak
less
interact less and they are more uh they
are more interested in something that
uh that they are in short they can be
very interested in
certain aspects we call it narrow
interest okay
um but that doesn't mean that it cannot
work so i think with
enough in uh with enough interaction
with the right environment actually
okay so the next question is actually on
robotics so it's an anonymous question
actually
the question is about how robotics can
help people with intellectual disability
in the workplace i know we didn't really
cover much about robotics in today's
presentation
so you can just feel free to share about
some of your views so we can also
have a discussion on it okay
all right so i just take this uh go
first so uh i give a very specific
example like in
in hospitals like fox could take but you
can see that there are robotics um
they're sending um either meals
or food or laundry or
clean linen to different parts of the
buildings right in the past these are
done by
done by people and some of the staff
there are actually people
with intellectual disability so now you
reduce
do you need to remember which item go to
which room
it's just stuck in on the robot
following instruction and they
make the sit back we call it we reduce
the step
do the work some are replaced by a robot
and by doing that you actually create
employment opportunity for someone on
with ids
yeah and if you are aware issuing
community hospital and could
hire quite a fair bit of a young adult
with intellectual decency
on my end i think for robotics is very
important in terms of the learning whole
process
uh it helps again i i think i also saw
one of the questions that talk about the
slightly
negative part of the robotics but i
don't think we will discuss that in
today's discussion
but i do believe that it will definitely
enable and help them it's a tool
like i mentioned early on i believe it
will be a tool to actually help more
people
to say for example learn more about ai
and through learning about ai for
example
they equip themselves and it creates
another new job opportunity for
themselves actually they
also as part of their learning process
they actually will be able to create
more job opportunities or more a wider
horizon of job opportunities for them to
choose from as well so that's what i
firmly believe that
in terms of robotics and its
applications is definitely uh
enabler and then of course it will be
seen as
helping much more and you know in terms
of i think francis has mentioned
different kind of
uh people with different kind of um
issues about learning they will be
actually i do i have
i believe i saw some research in a way
that there are some certain
uh uh patients that actually react even
better when talking to robotics instead
of actually a human as well for example
so i think there are some interesting
things about robotics that we can
actually
pick up on and basically be more open in
using it in terms of education
in terms of application into industries
yeah thank you
yeah so this is an anonymous question
that's directed at ian turn i know today
we spoke a lot about technology and
some of the useful applications in
designing for people with special needs
but this person is also asking given
that um we are also battling today with
misuse
of inaccurate information on social
media how can
this form of technology be protected
against i guess
future misuse
i will take this first apprentices maybe
you add in a little bit on what you feel
as well so i
might be a little bit more biased i
think definitely there are such
issues and i think the issue in this
recent environment these days is that
more and more people are discussing
about the ethical use of ai
in terms of their applications and i
believe you know technology like all
tools and equipment is a double age it
will have a uh the good side of it it
can also be used to do
not so good things i think in the in
place of certain standards
uh in the use in the use of uh uh
ethical applications i think with those
kind of global standards coming along
the way more and more people are
uh placing emphasis researchers to uh
technologies are actually focusing on
how do we actually protect it much
better
and then use it for the good purposes
and yet we cannot
eliminate the the use of this in the
wrong purposes
but how do we minimize it and since it's
already ai how does ai counter ai
i think these are a lot of discussions
and totally i think uh we will be able
to minimize it to a minimum i believe
and i think in this
particular application or into the
accessibility technology industry
i believe it helps more than it harms
more yeah
okay to follow up with what uh usa and
to use his technology as an example
for for someone who who has social
communication deficit
if you are ai you can help them to
structure communication
through a chatbot so by communication
itself
i can help you phrase a question i can
help you open up a conversation
i can even tell you this is a this is an
off topic our boundary
so ai can help to through machine
learning
through enough context can help so
instead of
giving a different life context which is
not possible
in this case ai can help shorten a
learning cycle
and help someone to pick up social
communication
skills through very real life mimic uh
situation that you can do
that you can use ai machine learning to
mimic the conversation and digitize it
to a chamber
so if you use properly i think it has a
lot of benefit for
someone with disabilities okay
yeah that's great now our next question
is actually directed at
trampoline but i think ian ten might
also be able to answer too so
the question is about do you have any
special tools or methods that you use to
obtain
user feedback or to validate some of the
tools and technologies that you
mentioned earlier for people with
special needs
okay i think the the user requirement
process
methodology are quite universal the
difference is actually in the
emphasis on different phases and which
method
is better for different for different
use cases and different
disabilities for example we do a lot of
economic graphic study or
use in layman term we go to study on
site
we walk in their shoe because that is
something that can help us
empathize why they can why are the
challenges they face
for example uh for smart bfa our staff
actually sit on the wheelchair and
navigate and then you find that actually
sitting on your chair
if you've tried before uh can be quite
uh
after a while yeah your buttocks will
feel pain that's the reason one of the
reasons why they they need to get from
point a to point
very fast okay yeah so you need uh so
it's in short
um overall process is the same
the technique that you use for a
different situation uh
it needs need to be adjusted according
to the use case
and i i think more um more
things like walking the shoe on
observation helps
okay yeah okay then the next question is
about i guess
how has are there any examples of how
technology has
failed to solve some of these problems i
know these are actually very complex
problems that cannot be solved in a very
simple and straightforward manner
but if you have not managed to solve
them are there any way what you have
done
differently or plenty failure is
failure is the mother or success we have
more failures than i can recall
okay uh but the reason save me the same
here
the reason is that sometimes we uh we
don't under there are a few reasons we
don't understand the needs
we identify the wrong problem statement
all right or
we try to over complicate things for
example um
it's quite natural for someone from
certain domains let's say if i'm a
uh if i let's say if i a a scientist
i'm a scientist emotionally i'll try to
use a lot of machine learning karma is a
solution
but does that really address the user
need okay
so one example will be the ai that i
just might mention it was so complicated
that we also cannot use and let alone
usb so so it has good intention but they
uh hence uh the outcome may not uh may
not be
what it is so it's very very important
to always validate with the user
to see that in an actual use case and to
go back to ask your question
uh did you meet your book give me your
outcome is the user using it
right if there's no point having a very
friend fantastic solution that
doesn't address the using yeah i would
like to add on to what francis has said
i think this has happened so many times
because especially i think that
direction was also towards technology
folks like us
where we sometimes you know from a
design or engineer perspective you just
want to
do it to attain the use of it but what
about the user experience
and a lot of times especially in the
accessibility field we might not be
inclusive ourselves in terms of our
consideration we might be thinking of
how a normal user like me and you will
be using the technology to solve their
problem
so i think the feedback is very
important and also addressing the
previous question just now how do you
get the feedback
i think it's really always a challenge
in terms of getting the feedback in
terms of the user base
however i would also say that with the
use of this technology we are able to
crowd source and consolidate defect
at an even bigger skill than uh ever
before
so i think that's the pros and cons of
the technology with the technology is
really good in a way that we can
get it to be scalable as long as we have
as many users
and then improve the product much better
that's what ai does it
improves on its own however on the other
side is really getting i think
more people on the base and to actually
open this off i just want to encourage
people not to be afraid of the failure
actually
for us we came on board not thinking
that we just wanted to contribute
we just think that oh somebody asked us
can you your your
technology be used in the leaf i say
yeah why not let's just do it don't
think too much i think this covid has
also taught our whole team that
sometimes we tend to think too much as
well in solving a problem
if there's certain things that we would
contribute and and reach out to
to solving the problem why not try it
first and then we learn along the way it
might not be successful
but then we learn throughout energy
through this whole process i think we
learn much more
and then it actually applies certain
knowledge and and help us to improve
certain things in other projects that
we're actually doing as well
yeah thank you so much pianist for this
engaging conversation we're actually
coming we've actually come to the end of
our q a segment
and i still see quite a few questions
that are still coming so what we'll do
actually is we'll answer them directly
either in the q a chat
or reach out to you via email after this
session to answer them
so to our attendees i really hope that
this session has inspired you
on ways you can incorporate technology
to create inclusive communities for
everyday living
designers we hope that this sharing has
inspired you as well to research into
new projects
that can promote accessibility in
communities and if so
the good design is actually an avenue
that you can tap on
our next open call for good design
research will be launched in october
and it welcomes research and
experimentation for design
impact driven project now i'll invite my
colleague que me back to quickly share
about upcoming open call
we may please hi
thanks jerica um so for those of you who
are keen on design and impact projects
and are actually seeking inspirations
and suitable project partners
we hope that this series of engagement
and sharing sessions is meaningful for
you
like what jericho mentioned we will be
launching our open call
in mid-october so do look out for our
edms as well as our social media posts
on the details of the launch
during the open call period we will also
be organizing a briefing session to
share in more detail
as to how to submit a strong proposal
in the meantime these are some brief
information on the support that we are
extending to the selected projects
as well as eligibility and assessment
criteria that you should be aware of
if you are keen to respond to the open
call so we will be supporting selected
projects up to the proof of concept
stage with
cash sponsorship publicity support as
well as mentorship
we will also be looking out for these
three key criteria in your submissions
first we are keen to know how we are
keen to know your long-term plans for
the project beyond the proof of concept
stage
the intent is to ensure that applicants
are committed to the project
secondly we are also looking out for
submissions that explores deep research
that addresses global issues such as
inclusivity and sustainability
and which goes beyond the standard user
research lastly we will also be looking
out for projects that strengthens the
applicant's
unique value proposition in the meantime
if you are keen to submit a proposal for
the upcoming open call
do express your interest in the post
event survey
and share your email contact so that we
may reach out to you for a chat
with this i'll pass the time back to
jericha
thank you huemi and thank you everyone
for taking the time to join us in
in this evening's discussion should you
wish to revisit today's notes
a summary of the session will actually
be shared with you via email
along with the relevant links on how you
can reach out to each of our speakers
appearing on your screen now should also
be two qr codes so scanning the qr code
on the left will lead you to a post
event survey
like what me he may mention if you'd
like to get in touch with us
find out more about the good design
research initiative or if you are
inclined to submit a proposal
please indicate accordingly and we'll be
happy to follow up from there
or if you'd like to find out more
information on programs national design
center has lined up
under the theme of singapore our home
scan the qr code on the right
also thank you so much francis and ian
turn for the wonderful sharing today
to our attendees we hope that you found
the session inspiring and meaningful we
hope to see you again at subsequent
events
or even your submissions under the open
call thank you and see you soon
thank you everyone thank you jerica
thank you